hey everybody this is vic
and today we're going to be testing out
four different celebrity taco recipes
to find out which one is actually the
best on today's lineup
we have recipes from danny trejo arun
sanchez eva longoria and the legendary
mexican artist frida kahlo i measured
out all the ingredients exactly as each
recipe stated and i got three taco
lovers to choose their favorite taco in
a blind taste test
so which celebrity has the best taco
recipe let's find out
first up is danny trejo's carnitas tacos
danny starts out by oven roasting a pork
shoulder for approximately three hours
then roughly chopping it into little
bits
then he puts it in a non-stick pan
patting down with the spatula
until we achieve a beautiful golden
brown now it's time to build first we
throw down our tortilla a layer of
carnitas some raw onions some pickled
onions then we garnish with a little bit
of cilantro
and there you have it danny trejo's
cardio tacos
okay this is my tortilla this is
something that we definitely use at my
household i'm excited
the red onions are a nice touch yeah
there's fire i love the onion
it definitely gives it a nice kick to it
that's what i'm talking about this is
like the tacos you get in the street
after you've been like drinking a few
beers this is definitely more like taco
truck
taco you get the full tortilla i see my
family cookies so this is really good
it's like cold basically i give it a
thumbs up this is really good
next up is arron sanchez he starts off
by marinating skirt steak overnight
then generously seasoning with salt and
pepper then he grills the skirt steak
for approximately five to six minutes on
each side
until he achieves a beautiful medium
rare
then he takes his skirt steak out and
let's rest for approximately 10 minutes
now it's sauce time adon starts by
baking his tomatillo sauce ingredients
and he throws it in a blender to combine
all the ingredients into a beautiful
tomatillo sauce
once the steak is rested now it's time
to chop it up and start building our
taco
he starts off with two warm tortillas
then he puts two to three slices of the
skirt steak topped with a teaspoon of
the tomatillo sauce some raw onions
then garnish with some cilantro and some
limes and there you have it
aroma sanchez's cardi asada tacos so
this one looks like it's presented
nicely i can definitely see the
tomatillo sauce on it
and salsa verde this is this looks like
my taco for sure
check this out i like the salsa
i'd love it if it were a little spicier
steak is really good
sauce is really good it's like coming
apart a lot
the meat is nice the steak is is really
good
and i just like more cilantro and onion
for sure to make it a taco taco
if it was uh on a scale of one to ten
i'd go with like
a five and a half it's a decent taco
it's not the best but it's decent
next up is eva longoria's taco recipe
she starts by putting together guacamole
by
dicing tomatoes and avocados
then she finely chops white onion and
fresh cilantro
then eva grabs her guac add salt and
lemon juice and stirs gently until
combined
next she takes her steak and seasons
generously with chili powder and salt
then she oils her pan and cooks the
steak for about five to six minutes per
side
until she gets a nice medium rare then
she thinly cuts her steak and sets it
aside
ooh that juice though then interestingly
she cuts her tortillas into squares
then she throws them on a pan and warms
them up until we get a nice color
and now it's time to build she adds a
couple of pieces of steak
chunky guac and holds it all together
with a toothpick
and there you have it eva longoria's
tacos okay this is such a cute little
taco
it looks like something that probably
get like a nice restaurant they'll
probably charge like 20
for like a little piece of taco let's
give it a try but let's take this off
because
i'm too clumsy simple ingredients but
it's
put together it's like really good it's
a great two biter taco for sure so i
definitely um
ask for more it's like a nice appetizer
toothpick through it
that way everybody picks up individual
like taco portions but it's good and now
the recipe you've all been waiting for
frida kahlo's tacos she starts off by
finely chopping serrano peppers
keeping the seeds in to make sure to
bring the heat and then frita
peels and seeds tomatoes and dices them
then in a non-stick pan frida combines
butter onions the serrano chilies and
our tomato mix
then she lets the mixture cook for 10
minutes until the tomatoes are
thoroughly cooked
then frida adds shrimp and cooks until
just heated through
frida starts your taco with a corn
tortilla adding the shrimp tomato chili
mix on the top
garnish with cilantro and lime and it's
ready to go damn son
this one looks good it has some chili
peppers in there i'm expecting a little
bit of heat i would like it if i had two
tortillas for sure because it's hard to
pick up but
a little bit of sweetness to it i love
that it's spicy it definitely has
jalapenos i can feel it
looking at the shrimp they're like nice
size shrimp i would definitely say it's
like a higher end green restaurant yeah
i can have
three of these for sure to go sorry
which celebrity has the best tacos time
to pick our winner
out of the four celebrity tacos my
favorite probably has to be
doing with the purple onions the onions
on this look like they're pickled
really good if you didn't cook it with a
machete then that ain't right out of
these four celebrity recipes i'm going
with birth steak nicely done
perfect toppings on it and it just
tasted the best it does make sense i
think she's done like other
things with food out of the four
celebrity tacos my favorite one has to
be the one with the toothpick because it
had the avocado
a small portion of the meat and it was
just a two biter
that i can definitely not feel guilty of
grabbing ten or five
whatever it is who is it oh okay
and there you have it eva longoria has
the best tacos which recipe should we
try next
leave a comment below
[Music]
you